o que eu posso aprender essa é uma
pergunta que a gente se faz quando
convidados para o evento inclusive um
evento como esse a gente vai dar
palestras a gente escolhe a qual nós
vamos comparecer ao evento eu gostaria
de estar presente e o que eu vou
aprender lá se não nos interessa a gente
não vai
a gente não paga não paga esse preço
para não aprender nada né e esta é a
palavra chave é a palavra chave que nos
motiva a pensar
bom se eu vou o evento vai ter alguém lá
que vai transmitir algum conhecimento
pra mim
bom eu tenho a expectativa de que existe
sim uma sala de aula
mesmo que seja num evento nós estamos
aqui hoje uma sala de aula que nós temos
paredes nós temos uma pessoa que está
transmitindo alguma informação eu espero
aprender desta pessoa algo algo que seja
importante para minha vida e que tenha
realmente significado nela
bom se nós pensarmos que este conceito
de sala de aula ele ainda é vigente nós
estamos sendo ultrapassados porque a
sala de aula entendida como era até
então ela já está ultrapassada a nossa
sala de aula é o nosso mundo isso não é
uma idéia nova isto já há muito tempo
muitas pessoas vêm dizendo mas qual é a
realidade disso hoje na nossa escola é
bastante difícil então esta proposta de
desconstruir a sala de aula entre quatro
paredes uma pessoa que transmite
conhecimento e outros que estão ali
querendo aprender já era a sala de aula
pode estar ali na calçada quando a gente
vai atravessar a rua a sala de aula está
dentro da nossa casa num momento de
lazer assistindo a filmes com nossa
família sala de aula está numa mesa de
jantar onde nós estamos comendo na
cantina da escola no pátio da escola
na sala dos professores é um evento onde
a gente leva alunos para assistir
nós podemos aprender portanto sala de
aula é o momento de aprender não é o
espaço físico e não são as pessoas que
têm valor numa sala de aula mas é o que
acontece nela e o que acontece ela pode
acontecer em qualquer lugar e isso é o
que me move me move a pensar que nós
temos uma decepção
norte professores nos decepcionamos
porque muitas vezes nós vamos lá propor
uma atividade o aluno instalados ouvindo
ea gente faz uma avaliação uma prova do
exame um teste um trabalho ea gente fica
corrigindo e a gente descobre que a
gente não ensinou nada o que o aluno não
aprendeu nada então essa decepção ela
vem com o professor e ela pesa nossos
ombros porque nós estamos sempre
tentando inventar alguma coisa nova para
que o aluno realmente o efetivo
aprendizado o que fazer com isso esse
peso não é só do professor esse peso
está também nas costas do aluno ele
também se preocupa porque se for uma
escola particular ele está pagando para
aprender
se ele não está pagando os pais estão
pagando se for uma escola pública ele
precisa aprender porque lá na frente num
futuro não muito distante ou talvez
assim ele terá de usar esse conhecimento
e agora essa decepção que está está ali
impregnada nos dois lados do professor e
do aluno está presente está nos matando
como é que nós vamos sair desta situação
e sermos felizes nessa profissão tanto o
professor quanto o aluno
aí vem a questão bom o aluno e é
imediato
como é que ele vai ser feliz quando ele
chegar o resultado ali na sala de aula
se ele está aprendendo onde ele vai
aplicar quantas vezes nós pais mães nós
professores ou nós alunos nos
questionamos puxa onde é que eu vou
aplicar isso vão empregar esse
conhecimento que eu estou aprendendo
eu não enxergo isto agora eu normalmente
enxergo isso é bom quando eu for
trabalhar eu vou saber fazer
quando eu vou ser mais velho quando eu
vou estar em eventos quando eu estiver
diante de pessoas
eu vou empregar uma fala melhor eu vou
poder escrever melhor
eu tenho que conhecer a história para
poder transformar o meu futuro mas
porque eu não estou transformando agora
porque eu não estou escrevendo agora que
utilidade têm essa minha escrita em sala
de aula eu vou fazer o quê com essa
minha redação
tem um avaliador muito bem mas agora o
que eu faço com tudo isso é importante
que o aluno tenha o resultado porque o
nosso aluno ele é imediatista
ele precisa ver e aí nós estamos muito
aquém dos recursos tecnológicos porque
os recursos tecnológicos são avançados o
que antes mudava de cinco em cinco anos
hoje muda de 10 e danos não hoje muda de
10 em 10 minutos nós estamos voltando
atrás né
nós estamos avançando o aluno tem hoje é
celular de última geração em sala de
aula talvez o professor não tenha o
aluno de dez em dez minutos de meia hora
de dar uma espiadinha o que está
acontecendo no mundo e às vezes nem lê
mas ele vê a imagem então a imagem está
se sobrepondo a função da escola o
professor já não é mais aquela imagem
bonita que ele gostaria de todos os dias
pela manhã e acordar enxergar olha que
maravilha vou ver minha professora hoje
seria muito bonito isso né
mas não existe então a imagem que está
ali corrente nacional na tecnologia ela
está nos afetando na sala de aula porque
não trazer esse inimigo para a sala de
aula porque não fazer com que esse
inimigo virem o nosso amigo este é um
problema e através deste problema é que
surgiu o projeto curta metragem o curta
metragem sala de aula dá muito trabalho
nós
uma pessoa sozinha não consegue
efetivamente dá muito trabalho
bom mas é um trabalho gostoso é um
trabalho que quando a gente acaba a
gente faz assim é legal
que coisa bonita e aí quando termina a
gente vem no evento assim compartilhar
com vocês os alunos pegam e dizia assim
valeu sobrinha que bacana vai lá sucesso
para ti isso já passaram anos
então este problema que surgiu em sala
de aula é discutido nas aulas de
sociologia professor de sociologia ótima
para isso porque ela tem um domínio
dessas questões reflexivas e fiquem
espetando os alunos a pensarem sobre
como esse seu martin modifica em sala de
aula
seu comportamento
tanto que leva esse resultado e nem na
vida e no restaurante e na tua casa
quantas horas por dia fica sobre o
celular
vendo imagens lendo notícias impactantes
bom e aí o aluno começa a pensar essa
reflexão nas aulas de sociologia levam a
pensar em temas
esse celular e apenas um tema mas nós
temos o bullying e nós temos a gravidez
na adolescência
nós temos a discriminação nós temos a
violência contra a mulher então variados
temas e temas problemáticos são
envolvidos na aula de sociologia e as
turmas se dividem em grupo
vamos estudar esse problema se esse
problema nos afeta como fazer para que a
gente tenha alcance o outro resultado
que atitude eu que estou envolvida neste
problema posso ter para que o resultado
disso seja outro bom aulas de sociologia
fica maravilhosa
a aula de língua portuguesa pega esse
problema e diz bom vamos fazer imagens
sobre isso vamos gravar um vídeo mostrar
a realidade e mostrar como ela pode ser
sim vamos bom todo o vídeo precisa de um
planejamento eu não posso simplesmente
pegar uma câmera e sair filmando e dizer
bom isso aqui é o meu curta metragem e
aí nasce o roteiro roteiro escrito que
precisa da ajuda do professor de língua
portuguesa o roteiro que precisa dos
sinais de pontuação que precisa de uma
estrutura sintática que tem uma
linguagem formal e informal porque nós
temos os descritores nós temos as falas
e nós temos as características dos
personagens que são os elementos da
narrativa que o professor de literatura
entra neste momento bom se nós estamos
gerando uma ficção afecção tem elementos
da narrativa que elementos nós temos que
personagens nós temos que figure nós
vamos utilizar qual será o cenário qual
é o tempo do curta em que momentos nós
vamos fazer esta este planejamento
dentro das aulas de literatura e aí
entra também a arte porque nós temos que
ter técnicas de filmagem iluminação sou
atuação desenvolver essa capacidade que
não é fácil porque não é fácil estar
aqui diante de uma câmera é muito
difícil e para o aluno
seis anos com 17 anos com 15 anos talvez
até seja mais fácil porque eles estão
mais relaxados eles são mais espontâneas
eles conseguem captar rapidamente tudo o
que precisa ser feito e eles são
críticos
eles sabem exatamente se estiverem aqui
filmando uma cena numa tomada ele sabe
não ficou boa
vamos fazer de novo e eles fazem na hora
porque eles vão refazer
quantas vezes nós professores em sala de
aula lutamos e pedimos assim é fácil
este exercício não está bom e eles não
fazem porque eles não gostam reforça
essa cena não ficou legal vai ficar
melhor da próxima vez com essa
iluminação e com essa roupa correndo
eles vão fazer e eles vão repetir
e essa mudança de postura de atitude
diante do que eu preciso fazer e fazer
melhor faz com que eles desenvolver essa
competência essa habilidade no futuro
eles não estão vendo isso lá no futuro
eles estão vendo isso agora quem é que a
gente quer para trabalhar conosco
pessoas que tenham bons relacionamentos
pessoas que conseguem mudar seu
comportamento sua atitude se adequando
aos espaços aos lugares
as atividades desenvolvidas então lá na
escola a gente consegue essa desenvolver
essas habilidades e fazer com que o
aluno fique competente nessa
transformação se nós queremos mudança
nós queremos mudança também na sala de
aula porque lá é o momento de se
exercitar a sala de aula que pode ser o
pátio a sala de aula que pode ser uma
sala de aula
a sala de aula pode ser um parque a sala
de aula pode ser a rua então esses
problemas trabalhados em sala de aula
eles estão ali competindo em igualdade
com jornais na televisão com a internet
com as redes sociais
ora nós estamos de fato trazendo um
inimigo para nós
nós estamos usando esses recursos
tecnológicos que muitas vezes nos
atrapalham para nos auxiliar
o inimigo virou amigo ou inimigo virando
amigo a gente tem inúmeras
possibilidades de trabalhar isso com
essas quatro áreas envolvidas
o trabalho não se torna pesado
dividir estas forças certo e aí nasce
sim um bom trabalho a partir de um
problema refletida em sociologia a
partir de um planejamento escrita em
língua portuguesa a partir de uma
visualização de todos os componentes da
literatura e no desempenho na arte nasce
esse projeto de curta metragem que nada
mais é do envolvimento integrado de
algumas disciplinas e poderiam ser
inclusive mais disciplinas para chegar
no resultado
a mudança do aluno real
agora mesmo que sendo ficcional no
ambiente superficial mas ele experimenta
essa possibilidade de fazer diferente ea
proposta é chegar ao final desse
trabalho enxergar um vídeo carregado de
imagens realizadas por eles com atitudes
e comportamentos diferentes daqueles que
vemos na realidade e eles chegam lá todo
curta metragem deve chegar no resultado
final ter uma proposta educativa
transformar aquilo que não está bom e
algo melhor enxergar isso uma imagem
enxergar o futuro mais próximo de nós
portanto usar esses recursos também não
é muito fácil nós professores mas para
os alunos é muito fácil eles dominam a
tecnologia em que momento a gente usa
equipamentos de alta tecnologia na sala
de aula no contra turno com materiais
dos alunos nós não temos estúdio
se a gente tiver gravar uma situação é
atravessando a rua era uma parada de
ônibus na casa de cultura mario quintana
é dentro da escola é da enfermaria da
escola fingindo ser um ambulatório do
hospital em qualquer espaço possível
porque a sala de aula o nosso mundo eo
nosso mundo está aí à disposição então o
inimigo virando amigo em sala de aula
os recursos utilizados pelos próprios
alunos que são melhores que os próprios
professores e o ambiente é o que nós
temos ali
saímos da possibilidade e entramos na
atividade
fazer os alunos se movimentarem vocês
vão ter um ganho muito grande e nós
professores vão sair mais felizes porque
eles querem o movimento
eles são pessoas agitadas eles querem
construir porque eles são criadores
eles são autores o computador para eles
é uma janela aberta eles ali eles se
realizam portanto eles gravam as cenas
várias vezes até encontrar uma cena boa
e depois passa a editar o vídeo e aí o
resultado é satisfatório por professor
sim para o aluno talvez muito mais
porque existe uma felicidade neste
resultado e temos então o resultado que
agrada não só o aluno que fez o
professor desenvolveu a escola que
ganhou a família que enxergou durante
todo esse momento algo sendo realizado
eu estou realmente muito feliz e queria
muito compartilhar essa experiência que
durante 45 anos da minha vida
no primeiro ano foi maravilhoso mas foi
bom no segundo ano a gente ajustar
algumas coisas e hoje nós estamos no
quinto ano fazendo esse mesmo projeto
com problemas diferentes a cada ano eu
fico muito feliz de poder compartilhar
isso com vocês muito obrigado
[Aplausos]